enoh reporter dans la capitale sucer
manifestation toute la journée
lucas léger et partie place de la nation
mobilisation sur appel des idées jeune
david khalifa lui et place de la
république au rassemblement statique
david bonjour à ce que la mobilisation
est au rendez vous
et bien pour le moment où me rase
arrivent au compte goutte et l'ambiance
est plutôt festive ici place de la
république pour ce rassemblement qui je
le rappelle est statique l'objectif et
le retrait pur et simple de la
proposition de loi est sécurité globale
une convergence des luttes puisque à des
artistes sont également présents ici
pour manifester contre les mesures
liberticides du gouvernement c'est ce
qu'il c'est comme ça qu'il est nos mains
ces mesures des mesures liberticides et
s'opposer à la fermeture des lieux
culturels imposée par le gouvernement de
vieux os coronavirus à plusieurs d'entre
eux venus ici à manifester dénonce une
dérive autoritaire du gouvernement
écouter pour moi c'est important pour
faut lutter contre le fait que qu'ils
veulent restreindre nos libertés et en
donner encore plus aux policiers qui ont
déjà beaucoup de liberté qui font leur
métier en toute impunité qu'il faut
montrer les images qui montrent les
violences et les bavures policières tout
à fait contre puisque c'est un projet de
loi qui vise quand même à aller vers un
état de plus en plus policier de
contrôle de répression et à une heure où
alors où on a effectivement besoin de
tous les moyens aujourd'hui de
s'exprimer de s'organiser du thé c'est
simple en france sur tous les jours tous
les bâtiments publics qui a marqué
liberté égalité fraternité
c'est un outil fondamental parce que
c'est ce que ce que prévoit cette loi
ben cdc s'est carrément l'abolition de
toutes les libertés
déjà qu'ils profitent beaucoup de la
crise de la crise du coc vide comme ils
ont fait d'ailleurs alors après les
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 pour pour
nous mettre dans l'est dans les textes
de loi et dans le droit commun destexhe
totalement attentatoire aux libertés et
cela pour prévoir des mesures
d'austérité encore plus important
l'article 24 acquiert remise en cause un
partout les manifestants haïtiens et qui
pénalisent la diffusion malveillantes
c'était forces de l'ordre en tout cas un
important dispositif de sécurité a été
mis en place en tout autour de la place
de la république
selon le préfet de police selon
plusieurs sources en tout cas au moins
52 unités de forces mobiles ont été à
déployer pour éviter tout débordement
qu'il ya pu y avoir lors des précédents
rassemblements
un dispositif totalement
disproportionnée un pur et rico qu'elle
est députée la france atomise écoutez
c'est un vrai souci quel que soit après
l'aller les raisons pour lesquelles les
gens manifestent mais c'est quand même
pas normal que maintenant on soit
habitué ans dans ce pays parce que si
tout court manifeste on soit
complètement encadrés par la police fin
je veux dire on a l'impression de fan
zone à chaque fois ça fait maintenant
plusieurs années que ça dure ça se
renforce avec le préfet l'allemand et ça
devient effectivement un souci pour la
démocratie alors non même quand ça se
passe tranquillement c'est déjà un souci
et puis en plus sincèrement il ya des
provocations donc vous avez on s'habitue
trop dans ce pays à une dérive
autoritaire
un rassemblement qui se déroule dans le
calme pour l'instant et de manière assez
un fait si vous le voyez derrière moi
une scène a été montée des prises de
parole se succèdent et à d un concert d'
avons également avoir lieu pour
protester contre cette proposition gras
sécurité globale tout au long de l'après
midi
ici place de la république merci à david
pour toutes ces précisions